so because i was sleep deprived i
blurted out something that normally i
wouldn't
i said nancy i didn't know it was so bad
and i can't help you kill yourself
but if you do
i will still think well of you
i will miss you
and maybe i'll understand why you had to
to get out of the pain
and that was the first time she looked
at me michaela
and she when she looked at me she
grabbed onto my eyes like i'm grabbing
onto yours
and i thought
she was going to tell me thank you for
understanding i'm overdue so i was a
little nervous because this is the first
time she made eye contact and i said
what are you thinking nancy
and then she leaned into me
and she said if you can really
understand why i might have to kill
myself to get out of the pain
maybe i won't need to
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 115. the guy i spoke with on
this episode doesn't have a social media
following but he's absolutely brilliant
this was one of the best podcasts i've
ever done i cried in it he's possibly
the best storyteller i've ever spoken
with he is mark goldston the creator
slash co-founder of michelangelo mindset
executive coach best-selling author of
nine books and host of my wake-up call
podcast he was originally a ucla
professor of psychiatry for over 25
years and a former fbi and police
hostage negotiation trainer
he shared absolutely fantastic anecdotes
and we delved into his work with
depression and suicidality and his
development of something called surgical
empathy and the michelangelo mindset
both of which he helped create we
discussed what people should want to
create in a conversation and tactics you
can use against bullies this guy's
insanely smart he really knows how to
read people and have them react in the
way he wants i think everyone would
benefit by learning some of his
techniques or if you want to know more
about how to help people who are dealing
with depression this episode is for you
if you enjoy this content please
consider subscribing i hope you enjoy
the episode
[Music]
mark goldstein welcome to my podcast
so glad to be here michaela
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
well i was trained as a psychiatrist
ucla trained psychiatrist
and one of my sub-specialty areas was
suicide prevention
i've been blessed to have eight mentors
they've all passed away and one of my
early mentors
was
one of the top pioneers in suicide
prevention he was at ucla
and so he would refer me still suicidal
patients who had to be discharged from
the inpatient unit but they weren't
acutely suicidal and the residents
didn't want to see them so he'd go up to
a consultation call me on the phone put
them on the phone
and they would be discharged and i would
see them
and one of the most fortunate things
that happened to me
was that i was signed up to do a
fellowship which fell through a week
before i finished training and i figured
oh well
i'll just go out there i have this guy
referring me these suicidal patients
and but this is what i discovered
michaela i discovered that when i was
with people
and
they were talking to me and i
looked into their eyes
they were screaming out at me in their
eyes you're checking boxes and i'm
running out of time
and so i had a choice check the boxes
or throw away the boxes and see where
their eyes took me
and i was fortunate because if i had
gone into a fellowship or worked for an
institution
i'd be so busy checking boxes
that people would be saying well you
left protocol why'd you ask that
question
why'd you follow up with that
but what happened is it was so
penetrating when i looked into their
eyes
that i just
learned to
look for where it would take me
and i actually wrote an article after
anthony bourdain died by suicide and
kate spade
and it had 500 000 views in 10 days
maybe because the title was why people
kill themselves it's not depression
so there's a little hook there
and i said
there's hundreds of millions of people
maybe billions who are depressed who
don't kill themselves
it may contribute to it
people have lost marriages
most people don't kill themselves but
what i observed by listening into
people's eyes
is what most of them had at the end was
despair
and if you break the word despair into
d-e-s
p-a-i-r they feel unpaired
hope less without a future
help less power less useless worthless
meaningless purposeless
and when they all line up pointless
and so they pair with death
to take the pain away
because death feels their pain
and if they can feel that you feel their
pain
without trying to
treat them or throw stuff at them
because they scare you
they will often detach
from death as the relief
to something that i call surgical
empathy
wow
okay
that this is a lot
surgical empathy so
did that
mean sorry that was a lot to take in did
that mean that you ended up with
patients that became attached to you
well i think they became attached to the
the empathy and and of course since i
was the therapist they were attached but
now i'm retired now i'm still licensed
and so i'm going around the world
teaching
parents and anyone who'll listen to me
in the time i have left in my life
you know how to connect
with the people you're worried about
and that you love let me share an
anecdote which will
which kind of turned things around so
there i was
a
freshly minted psychiatrist mentored by
this suicide expert
and there was one patient that i will
call nancy that's not her name and she
had made two or three suicide attempts
before i
started seeing her and i was seeing her
for about six months and i didn't think
i was helping her at all i mean really i
mean she'd come in she wasn't catatonic
and she would always look you know 30
degrees to the left or right of me she
wouldn't make eye contact
and i used to moonlight at a state
psychiatric hospital once a month where
i'd cover for the other psychiatrist and
sometimes you don't sleep for 24 hours
or more
so i remember i had just come back from
moonlighting
and there was monday and there i was
with nancy
and so i'm sleep deprived
and she's there not looking at me
and as i'm looking out of my room all
the color turned to black and white
so i'm looking out of the room and it's
black and white
and i thought i'm having a stroke or a
seizure
so i did a neurologic exam on myself i'm
a psychiatrist not a psychologist so you
know i'm looking at my fingers tapping
my tapping my elbows tapping you know
and like this to see if i'm all there
and i realized i'm all here i'm not
having a stroke or a seizure
and then i had this crazy idea that i
was looking at the world through her
eyes feeling her feelings and i just got
the chills and it got colder and colder
oh it gets it gets it gets more uh
michaela so because i was sleep deprived
i blurted out something that normally i
wouldn't
i said nancy i didn't know it was so bad
and i can't help you kill yourself
but if you do
i will still think well of you
i will miss you
and maybe i'll understand why you had to
to get out of the pain
and that was the first time she looked
at me michaela
and she when she looked at me she
grabbed onto my eyes like i'm grabbing
onto yours
and i thought
she was going to tell me thank you for
understanding i'm overdue
so i was a little nervous because this
is the first time she made eye contact
and i said
what are you thinking nancy
and then she leaned into me
and she said if you can really
understand why i might have to kill
myself to get out of the pain
maybe i won't need to
wow and then she smiled
and then i held onto her eyes
and i said here's what we're going to do
i'm not going to give you any treatments
or that you've been through before
unless you tell me maybe we should try
another treatment because this has been
going on for five years
would that be okay
and i'm holding on to her eyes
and she
had a look that said keep talking she
said yeah
and then i leaned in and i said what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to find you wherever you
are
and i'm going to keep you company
god man i just don't want you to be
there alone
would that be okay
and then she started to tear up
and you know i mentioned before we
started this getting me
can you feel it sort of michaela
oh yeah well i'm i feel like i'm kind of
in tune to those things and i've been to
some pretty dark places so yeah keep
going keep going
so
uh something we'll talk about hopefully
later in the interview i've i've
started a company called michelangelo
mindset
and
michelangelo has a quote that says
i saw the
i saw the angel in the marble and kept
carving until i set it free
so he would look into a piece of marble
and see the statue of david or he'd see
a paeda
and what i realized
with my suicidal patients
i saw the hope in them
that they couldn't see or feel
and i just carved away everything that
got in the way of their seeing it or
feeling it
and i think what got in the way
is they scared people
they worry
i saw one patient
i said what helps
in our meeting
and he said
you're the only person i'm not a worry
or burden to
i said what do you mean
he said my parents are worried
my siblings think i'm manipulative which
i am
[Music]
the other doctors i've seen you know
were very good and very professional
you know but you have this smile when
you see me like you're glad to see me
and it's not about whether i followed
you know taking my medication
and so i thought you were crazy dr
gulstan
but you were the only place where i'm
not a burden because
something people who aren't suicidal
don't realize
is if you feel like this burden to the
world
and you have no happiness
why don't you just relieve the world
of that burden
so you're tracking with me kinda
oh yeah
like i've had so i've been in chronic
pain from the arthritis i had multiple
surgeries i've been on a lot of
medication i'm not on anything anymore
everything's in remission i haven't
taken a
psychiatric medication since i was 23
and i'm 29
so i got off of those which was hell in
itself
but i am very familiar with those
feelings and
my dad we've made this pretty
pretty uh um we've been vocal about this
but my dad experienced akathesia
from psych meds
which people kill themselves when they
experience academia
quite frequently and so
it was like
just terrible and it when you're dealing
with someone or if you yourself are in
that kind of state
you do feel like a burden
and
you do get blamed a lot and you're told
you're manipulative and
so yeah i am totally on board i also
found it interesting that you said
that things went black you know you were
sleep deprived so there was that but
things went black and white when i
stopped taking um i stopped taking my
ssris way too rapidly over a period of
two weeks and i'd been on them for like
12 years
bad idea but i had very severe ssri
withdrawal and during
the first maybe like couple of years but
particularly the first year
when the withdrawal got bad because it
kind of went in cycles
i couldn't see color like that happened
to me reds went less vivid and
everything kind of went gray and i was
like there's so little joy in the world
you don't even notice when color gives
you joy you don't even really notice
that but when it was way away i was like
oh i can't even see red very well so i
must be getting some joy from that that
i'm not getting anymore so yes we're on
the same page
definitely
well i'm glad you're in a better place
oh yeah much better
you know something i i i
i have a friend he became my friend
a couple years ago after his a year
after his 14 year old son died by
suicide
and his name is jason reed and he
reached out to me and we've been doing
programs for an organization called eo
entrepreneur organization in fact we're
going to do a live presentation to 500
members in reno in october and on
september 22nd
we're doing two 90-minute presentations
globally to ypo so ipl is young
president's organization so we're doing
a global zoom call
to the whole organization
because one of his the suicide notes
that his son left
was
tell my story and he put in over two
hundred thousand dollars and he has a
documentary called tell my story
and you can see it still for free if you
look up tell my story film
and it
you can't watch it in one setting
because
it's so heart-wrenching and he went up
and down the west coast of
the united states to find out
why people kill themselves why his son
killed himself
and he did a goal cast video
which had
nine million views
and he spoke to about a dozen male
entrepreneurs and he's a serial
entrepreneur
and he said to them it was my fault
he said you know when you're an
entrepreneur
you solve problems you give people
answers you give people advice and also
you don't share with your family that
you're afraid from all the failures you
know you're the man you're the guy and
so you don't show vulnerability and he
basically said i made it impossible for
my son to open up to me
because
i would just give him answers
and and he shared this interesting
observation which i use everywhere
he said you know when you talk to your
teenager
and you say hey how you doing and they
say great
they're usually good
but when they say i'm fine
they're not
i'm okay
yeah
i'm okay or just leave me alone i don't
want to talk about it
so he actually has something maybe we
can put a link to it if you look up teen
mental health webinar
okay
it has on youtube you'll find his gold
cast 9 minute video and then for 20
minutes
is me giving advice to parents if you're
worried about your your teen or your
20-something and they're in a dark place
here are some of the things that might
open them up to you
great
i'll link a bunch of these things below
i'll link those events too
and teen mental health webinar okay
i hope you're enjoying the episode this
episode is brought to you by
super specio
the kratom company i support
kratom is a herb related to the coffee
plant the leaves or extracts from the
leaves have been used as a stimulant and
a sedative it works on opiate receptors
in the brain so it's been used to treat
chronic pain digestive ailments and aid
in withdrawal from opiate dependency i
always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood before anything else
diet exercise saunas avoiding
inflammatory foods and poison but if
you're still having trouble and you've
already tried
other things and you felt like they
weren't quite what you were looking for
kratom might be worth a shot it's great
for energy support some people use it as
a substitute for coffee or pre-workout
some people use it to manage stress or
to help them relax or for their sore
throat that their toddler gave them
the most important part of
superspisiosa i think and the reason i
support them is their kratom is reliable
third-party lab tested and approved
under the american kratom association's
quality standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
remember because this works on opiate
receptors it can cause addiction if you
way overdo it so do your research google
everything you take be super paranoid
know your [ __ ] i do
i've been someone who's come off of
opiates multiple times from surgeries
and wish i had known about something
like kratom while i was doing that so if
you want to try it out
you can go to
getsuperleaf.com
and enter code mp for 20 off that's get
getsuperleaf.com also linked below
slash mp
promo code mp for 20 off i hope you
enjoy the rest of the episode
okay so
you
strike me as someone in order to be able
to look into somebody's eyes and
recognize what's in there
um
not to sound too sure of myself and
possibly because i've been in really
dark places i can see that like it hurts
me i can look into people's eyes and i
can like feel that
but i don't think that everybody
everybody can as easily perhaps so with
your michelangelo mindset are you trying
to teach people how to do
that well
michelangelo mindset
teaches people to see into their future
and then make it happen
so for instance i work with a number of
entrepreneurs
and
and we're writing a book i have a
co-author uh and the subtitle uh is how
michael how michelangelo mindset
can free
success happiness and fulfillment in
your life just like michelangelo freed
the statue of david
and so for instance when i speak with
startups and entrepreneurs
i say the secret to success
is you have to
increase self-discovered urgency in
other people
because if you try to convince them
you'll scare them away especially after
covin
everybody feels pushed around and
bullied by covet
and so when you come on strong
and you're pushing at someone
they're going to resist they're going to
smile politely because you're making
them nervous
so what you really want to do
is
discover in help them to self-discover
some a sense of urgency because urgency
makes them act
and usually
what causes people to have
self-discovered urgency i'll use an
acronym that we that's overused is fomo
it's the fear of missing out on
something terrific
you know that's why you see when
everyone's selling such and such oh this
is time limited you know you you can get
it you know before the before the new
apple laptops come in get the get the
latest one with the new chip on special
at such and such it's going away this
week
yeah and then they'll give it a week
break and then it'll be the same price
in two weeks
so but what you want to do
with other people
is find a way to help them discover
uh on their own
urgency
does that make sense
oh completely completely i think when i
talk so i told i don't know remember if
i told you earlier but i changed my diet
dramatically and that's what i'm that's
how i managed to get my autoimmune
symptoms and mental disorder
under control and i think that when i
talk to people about that and describe
what i've been going through
um
i think potentially part of what i do is
try and create a sense of urgency like
but
back to you
what what are you trying to keep what
are you trying to create a sense of
urgency towards are they entrepreneurial
ventures or is it or what is it well i'm
i'm
i'm creating a course with an
international accelerator
that's home based in southern california
and so they have cohorts of about uh 20
startups from around the world and every
three months
i do
a presentation and the ceo says
you know these people just want more of
you mark
uh i'll share something because that's a
little bit lighter than what we've been
talking about
uh and and hopefully it'll put a smile
on both of our faces my caleb because
right about now we get
so these are startups that are basically
getting to the end of their friends and
family money so they have to go to
investors
so uh
and and what i've told them is i said do
you ever speak to investors
and they smile after a few minutes and
you think it's a yes and it isn't
and they say that happened just
yesterday i said here's the deal
investors don't smile
it's it's about money here's why they're
smiling
in two and a half minutes
of a 20-minute presentation they've
already decided they don't want to give
you money
and they're smiling because they don't
want to be rude because they start all
the time you put into your your
powerpoint and so they're smiling like
this but they've already decided it's a
no that's why at the end of it you think
they're going to say how do we get
started and they say well let me think
about it very interesting and you never
hear them again
and and these people in the zoom calls
oh my god that's exactly what they're
doing and i said so here's
here's a little bit of a michelangelo
mindset
and how you can see into people find out
where they're coming from
so i'm glad this is on video i think
you'll like this so when they smile and
you know that the smile is not a yes
it's a no but they don't want to be rude
what you say to them and i give them a
script is can we pause for a moment
and they're worried because they're
afraid that you caught them being rude
inside and smiling so that you don't see
it and they go what
yeah can we pause for a moment and they
go
okay
and then you look at them and you hold
them in your eyes
and you say when we started this
conversation
we were like this
here was you with money
here is me with a company that needs
money and now we're like this
here is you with money here is me with a
company that's not going to get any of
it
so you were listening for something or
looking for something
and you didn't see it or hear it
so in the time remaining
you know if you get the rest of the
presentation what were you listening for
or looking for
and what's happened is you've totally
disarmed them
and they're going to go what
you could say i think what you're
looking for and listening for
is an investment that's going to work
especially to make up for the
investments in your company that haven't
worked
so why don't you can you tell me about a
big winner that someone in your company
brought in or you brought in
and so you get them to talk and the more
they talk the more they're invested in
you
and here's where you turn around a
conversation that was at a dead end into
a ongoing relationship
and you say and then you say oh we could
cover those things but if you can't
cover them
you say you know i'm in a group of a
bunch of startups
and i could introduce you to three
companies
that fit what you're looking for
and i can send you information on them
and i'm not gonna tell them you know so
i'm not gonna have them hitting on you
but might i send you some information
from some of the other startups that
might be a good fit for you
and then if you like it i'll make an
introduction so what's happened
is you took a relationship where they
were smiling and you were never going to
see them again
and now you're focused on their success
you're not focused on yourself you're
going to introduce three other startups
to them and so everybody's going to be
grateful to you
and you can go back to all of them
afterwards because you've just started a
relationship built on generosity
wow
that is brilliant
so then you end up with people who are
in sales meetings that aren't going to
go well helping out the other companies
in the startups
on the presumption that these other
companies are kind of doing a similar
thing for them and you're only offering
people companies that you think suit
them what they're looking for so people
must be very familiar with the companies
in in the michael
michelangelo mindset correct
absolutely and in fact i'm going to i'm
going to give you
um
when we write the book
there is a statue of david
in the michelangelo mindset that you
need to create and i've already created
it at least three times with you
do you want to know what it is
yes indeed
what you want to create in a
conversation with other people
is for them to go think wow
hmm
yes
and what wow is i can't believe what i
just saw heard or read and with my
suicidal patients they couldn't
believe what they felt because they felt
hope
the hmm
is
this is too good to ignore
and then the yes is this is how i see we
can use it sold
so for a year and a half i've done a
bunch of things and this i didn't send
you in my bio because it's a little
dated but for a year and a half i played
steve jobs coming back from the dead
i had the turtleneck on i had the
glasses on
and the whole purpose of this
presentation where i played him from
to 2007 when he came back to apple and
introduced the iphone
was to show
a two and a two minute video
which was a dramatization
of steve jobs discovering the mouse and
the graphical user interface at xerox
park
and if you're watching this or listening
look up xerox park national geographic
steve jobs and it takes you right to it
and in the dramatization
and we could even play it but i'll
imitate it here's my steve jobs things
i'm not going to run get the turtleneck
and so in in the uh in the video
and you'll see and i'll just play him
and you'll see the wow yes
so he's like this smartest man in the
room
you know there at xerox park
he sees the xerox technician using the
mouse and the icons
and he leans in
and you see on his face this wow i can't
believe what i'm seeing
and then smartest man in the room says
to the technician
can i try it
and so then he sits down
and when his index finger touches the
mouse and the icons go on the screen he
starts to sweat
and steve wozniak is with him and
actually on this video clip wozniak
gives some commentary
and and steve jobs looks back at wozniak
and wozniak said when he looked at me
for the whom
because steve wozniak was a thinker
steve wozniak said i told i told him
once they go there they're not going
back
they're not going to go back to typing
and then uh and then the video goes on
and steve jobs is playing with the mouse
and then walter isaacson who wrote one
of the books comments
they didn't know what to do with this at
xerox
and so what was happening is steve jobs
was thinking hmm we got to do something
with this
and then the clip ends
with walter isaacson saying
they didn't know what to do at xerox but
steve jobs went back to apple
and here's the yes and created the
macintosh
so can you see that that whoever you're
with
and i think
am i right that i've created a few wild
yeses with you in the in in our
conversation already oh definitely i
think right away at the beginning
so that's what you that's what you want
to do and by the way
why we call that the statue of david is
isn't that what you felt when you
finally met the person you were going to
marry
you know when you thought to yourself
this is the one wasn't there a while yes
you know when you didn't know if you
could buy that tesla and it was more
than you could afford but when you went
there it was irresistible
and if you think about it
the way steve jobs and elon musk make
presentations it is overflowing with
triggering while yes
that's got to be difficult for the
average person to do though i mean
you're talking about people who have iqs
that are through the roof is there
something that the average person can do
to get that kind of reaction i mean
you're clearly very smart
well i think what you can do is
first of all
you need to have some
self-awareness
and realize that the more pushy you are
the more anxious you come off
and you come off as hungry
and all you actually have to do
is have
a beginner's mindset
which means you have an open mind
and all you have to be is curious what
they're listening for
i spoke in moscow along with a nobel
prize winner daniel kahneman he wrote
thinking fast and slow oh yeah i've read
that yeah and uh and it was interesting
because i i asked them i said why are
you having me you know i i
i'm i'm not daniel kahneman i'm not a
nobel prize winner i'm not jordan
peterson why the heck would you have me
and they said they said and here's a
wild yes they said doctor
his book did not go viral
so
here's some here's a little tip on
creating titles
so here's a tangent but it's a good
nugget
what you want to do is expand mental
real estate in people's minds
and the person who introduced that term
to me was a fellow named tony baxter he
was one of the lead imagineers at disney
and he said pirates of the caribbean
owns the word pirates in the minds of
kids
so disney owns pirates and they think of
pirates of the caribbean so what you
want to do is come up with something
that seems familiar
that gets in
and then you twist it and you get more
mental real estate so the english
version of the book they're referring to
is here it's called talking to crazy and
again this is not about mental illness
it's about how do you deal with people
who drive you crazy so that has some
mental real estate because when i told
people i'm writing a book called talking
to crazy they said oh i need that today
you know because i deal with that every
day
but
when it went to russia the title became
how to talk to [ __ ] and it went
viral
that was the translation that was the
translation
russians uh that's great but can you see
but that's a wild yes oh yeah so so you
want to grab people like that
oh that's interesting i can't believe
that they switched the title that badly
yeah well um the
i spoke with
who wrote the subtle art of not giving a
[ __ ]
mark
mark mark manson thank you very much
that could have been bad yeah and i mean
that's another one of those titles that
really takes off oh the book's valuable
too but
interesting there was a book i was going
to write but it's too negative for me in
my life but this is an automatic
bestseller and if you're listening you
want to write it it's a best seller and
and it's called get even plus 10
yeah that's a good one how to never be
taken advantage of or bullied again
do you have wisdom on how to never be
taken advantage of or be bullied again
we could delve into that a little bit
absolutely well i think i think the
first thing is realize that
the more eager
or the more you want something the more
vulnerable you are
okay so you have to play a game yeah and
i'll share an anecdote because in my uh
i give talks i i
was one of the few male speakers at the
women in technology international summit
and there's a couple thousand women and
you know probably
15 or 20 men that spoke in the two or
three days
and my topic was never be bullied again
and
you like my anecdotes can i share an
anecdote that oh yes i love your
anecdotes yes
so
uh
this is where this is before you were
born i believe
but i i say to people do you know where
you were on september 6 1995
and people said what what the heck are
you talking about
and i said let me refresh your memory
there was a trial going on in america
maybe you've heard of it it was called
the o.j simpson trial
and
on september 6 1995
one of the characters in that trial was
a fellow named detective mark furman
and he may have brought the case down
because towards the end of the trial he
had said that he had never said the
n-word and then there was proof that he
did say the n-word and things really
fell apart after that and on that day
detective mark furman
was questioned by a famous lawyer f lee
bailey
and detective mark furman
took the fifth amendment
why am i bringing this up because
everybody in the world who watched that
trial saw him taking the fifth amendment
except me
because i was sequestered in the top
floor of the criminal courts building
because i worked with the prosecution
during the trial and f lee bailey had
accused me of drugging him or coaching
him in his testimony during the
cross-examination earlier in the trial
so in the middle of the trial
detective mark furman came on you know
came across as like john wayne really
strong
and i got subpoenaed
to come in to see if i did anything with
him and i didn't do anything with him
but the subpoena never reached me
because it went to a building that i was
in that fell down in the 1994 earthquake
so the subpoena couldn't find me
i have it framed on a wall somewhere
so they just couldn't find me after that
and so the trial
went along
and then it was towards the end of the
trial
and i was there by myself
and i was wondering what's going to
happen
and
one of the crazy things about me
is
i always put myself in situations that
seem impossible
and i
i get to the brink of panic but i never
panic i get smart
in one of these days i'm going to have a
massive stroke with a smile on my face
because i will figure out the secret to
peace on earth and i'll die
so what happens is i'm there waiting i'm
getting anxious i'm getting nervous i'm
thinking i'm being set up and and and
then
about 5 p.m
i suddenly figure out f lee bailey and
80 percent of what i know about
difficult people
one thing that nearly all difficult
people have in common
and this is not just the venters this is
the whiners this is the stonewallers
this is the sullen people it's everyone
one of the things they all have in
common
is uh
sometimes they will charm you
or else why would you have them in your
life to begin with then they'll
frustrate you
then they'll anger you
then they'll outrage you
and many most people are uncomfortable
with becoming enraged
so when you're there and you're outraged
and you're uncomfortable becoming
enraged you will do everything you can
to keep a lid on it because you feel
like you're going to go out of control
so difficult people push us into our
feeling enraged
and i knew he was going to do that with
me because i'd watched him in the court
so i knew that when he came up at 7 00
p.m and he was there with a
uh an associate of johnny cochran and i
was there with one of the other
prosecutors
i knew he was going to charm me
frustrate me anger me in and
outrage me and then
hope that i become enraged
so you're going to like this miguela so
what he didn't know
is that i had long cultivated that
ability to look into people's eyes and
hold their eyes
i can i can hold your eyes wherever i go
and i could almost hypnotize you by
looking in your eyes
and so when he came in
i had him so figured out
uh
that i
started fumbling you know with pens and
whatever and bill hodgman one of the
prosecutors said to me mark
mr bailey's here he's going to ask you
some questions
and i and i said to
bill hodgman one of the prosecutors oh
okay bill
and then
f bailey sits down and across the table
from me and then when he sits down i
lock on to his eyes
oh
and i can do whatever i want with his
eyes and i go like this to make sure
that i'm locked on to them
and he doesn't know what i'm doing
and then he starts sharing he says uh
you know we don't exactly know your role
here dr golson
and here's what i realized about
innuendo innuendo is when people make
statements instead of questions
and when people say
something like
we don't really know what your role is
what we usually do when someone makes a
statement is we go uh-huh
and when we go aha they put a hook in
our neck and reel us in
and and we're here to find out you know
what your relationship with detective
mark furman is and normally people go
uh-huh
but instead of going aha
i just kept looking in his eyes
and i blinked
and then he made
six or seven more statements and i could
tell that he was wanting me to go aha
but instead i just kept looking at him
and i blinked
and then after about
five minutes
the prosecutor says to me mark you
haven't said anything
meaning i didn't say aha i didn't say
anything
and here was my moment of david speaking
of day stature of david and goliath i
looked at bill hodgman and i said
he hasn't asked me a question
and then i looked back and i looked at
bill and i looked back at ethere bailly
and fd bailly sort of flinched a little
bit
and i think he figured out maybe there's
more going on with this guy
so he started asking questions
and i looked at him and here's my
picture as i'm looking into his eyes i'm
not perfect but i'm not
i'm not protecting someone who killed
two people what's your story
so that was my mindset
and clearly there wasn't even a reason
for me to be pulled in because he had
taken the fifth amendment if he hadn't
taken the fifth amendment you know then
it made sense to interview me to see if
he purged himself so i'm not even sure
why they we even had this conversation i
think it's because he may have been
frustrated that the subpoena didn't
reach me from earlier in the trial
and so
so he starts asking questions
and
in the trial there was a famous phrase
that he used
where he pushed detective vermin and
said so you're here to say that you've
never said the n word
so again f lee bailey would start out
calm he'd frustrate you he'd anger you
he'd outrage you
and hope you go off balance so i knew he
would do that with me
and he starts picking up speed
and i'm you know just giving him you
know
one word answers and there was a point
in which he says so you're here to say
that you would never you didn't medicate
you didn't coach
you didn't do anything to affect
detective mark furman's testimony
so he you follow me he built up this
crescendo
and so there's like five people in the
room i'm looking into his eyes in my
peripheral vision i can see everybody
wants to hear what i have to say
here come the sirens to take me away but
uh uh
and so he i'm looking into his eyes i
count to seven
and then i go
and when i do that everybody looks leans
in i can see in my peripheral vision
because they want to hear what you know
what the shrink has to say
and then i said really and then i did
some innuendo with him i said mr bailey
and he goes uh-huh
[Laughter]
i said mr bailey
um
my mind wandered the last six or seven
minutes and it seemed very important
what you were saying can you repeat
everything
anyway what
i said yeah uh you know it's 7 p.m my
car is locked in a lot i don't know how
i'm gonna get it
but it seemed important what you were
saying
so could you run it by me again because
my mind wandered
and see people
who are bullies they don't care about
having substance
because if they can provoke you and
you're off balance
you know then they push you over the
edge
um
sorry about that
we don't exactly have a studio here you
know
don't worry about it yeah but uh
and so
so he looked at johnny cochran's
associate carl douglas and said what did
i say
because see again bullies don't have to
have substance if they can provoke you
enough
oh that's
that's interesting so he was just doing
a game
what did i say yeah yeah and so and so
he shared some of those things and the
point is i had nothing to hide because i
had nothing you know i didn't do
anything with
furman and so after a few more minutes
he looks at the prosecutor of me and he
says i don't think we have to call dr
gulstan on the stand the point is it was
a moot point he was just doing it for
ego because furman had taken the fifth
amendment i don't even know why i was
still up there
and so he gets up to leave
and i said
mr bailey i have a question for you
and bill hodgman the prosecutor is about
eight inches taller than me so we're
standing up and he says mark mark it's
the end of the trial it's okay
uh
i said uh
you know how earlier in the trial there
was a statement that once you bring the
n word out
you can't unring a bell meaning once
black people hear the n word spoken by a
white person
you can't unring the uh
the the anger that is triggering them
and he says yes so
and i said well yesterday in front of
the world
you said you were going to interview me
about detective mark furman
and so you associated me with the most
despised
cop in america today
so you slurred me do you have any idea
how we can unslur a slur
and so bill hodgman says to me mark mark
they misspelled your name don't worry
about it
and
and ethel bailey looks at bill hodgman
like who's your little friend
and so ethely bailey leaves the room and
i'm gathering my papers together and
then he comes back into the room and he
looks at me and he says i will trade you
a retraction
in tomorrow's newspaper
if you tell me what you figured out
about me
and i said ah that's okay that's fine
but can you but
i hope that lived up to my promise of a
good anecdote but can you see how much
you can teach all of us
about people who mistreat us
so here's here's the tip because your
listeners love tactics make a list
take a sheet of paper out draw a
straight line down the middle on the
left side write down the names of all
the awful people you have to deal with
that trigger you that bully you that
frustrate you that make you crazy
and on the right side write down all the
names of people that
make your life wonderful
those people that you don't thank enough
because you're too busy you know feeling
frustrated by the people on the left
side
and look at that list
and whenever you're about to deal with
anyone on the left side
hold a little bit of yourself back
so never expect them not to be difficult
so don't be aloof but listen to them and
then when they pull that difficult thing
you can say what i said can you say that
again or
you can say can can you say that to me
kind of in a regular voice because the
way you said it got me all kind of
agitated
or the simplest way to respond to it is
huh
and then here's the important thing
make a point of reaching out to the
people on the right side
of that sheet of paper
reach out to them and let them know how
grateful you are to them
because one of the worst things we can
do in life
is fail to be grateful to the people
who've been wonderful to us because
we're so caught up with all the people
that are negative
that's really smart
i agree
i think there's a lot of evidence that
practicing gratefulness can be very
beneficial
and just turn away turn around how you
think especially if you've had a hard
life
and lots of people have hard lives right
but there is something to that i always
underestimated the role gratefulness
could play because i was so sick and so
angry and on so many medications i was
like
what am i grateful for like what
but so i do have an easier time now that
i'm feeling better because it's more
obvious but
i definitely understand where you're
coming from there those were wild
stories okay i've got i've got a
question before we stop this
you seem to be incredibly stable
so it's interesting that you've come up
with a way to really read into people
and understand what's behind their eyes
because i would assume that that's more
of a compassionate thing
but i know that a lot of people who are
compassionate i think can be kind of
drawn into these battles
with triggering individuals
so
like emotionally are you is it hard to
bug you are you stable emotionally
yeah can i share one story and i'm gonna
get a little emotional about it
yes
definitely
um
one of my greatest accomplishments
personally
is i dropped out of medical school twice
and and graduated
and i think i dropped out twice for
untreated depression
so the first time i dropped out i took a
leave of absence
i worked in blue collar jobs and i just
loved it it was just so simple work was
you know i'd work from nine to five you
know go back to the apartment i was
staying in you know didn't bring it home
with me
and then i
my mind came back probably to a blue
collar level i came back to medical
school
and i lasted for another three months
and so i asked for a second leave of
absence
and when you take a leave of absence
from medical school the medical school
loses matching funds so i met with the
head of the medical school
uh the dean and he cares about funding
it i mean you know i was naive uh way
back then and so i don't even remember
the meeting but the dean of students
calls me and says i got a letter here
from the
other dean
and you better come in
and the dean of students was this
wonderful
man named william mcnary and we called
him mack
shows me the letter
and he says in the letter says i've met
with mr ghoulston we talked about
another career i'm advising the
promotions committee that he'd be asked
to withdraw so that's from the dean of
the whole school
and i said to mac i said what does this
mean he said you've been kicked out
and i cratered in front of him i mean it
was like a gunshot wound and i know what
that feels like because i had a
perforated colon about 12 years ago i
almost died it felt just like that
and i came from a background you know
hard-working parents but it was a
depression background where you're only
worth what you can do in life if you
can't do anything you're worthless
and so i was feeling pretty low
so
something i had done during that time is
i wrote a poem called lament for the old
that got published in a geriatric
psychiatry journal
and in the poem i basically talked about
how
how the medical profession was
abandoning older people because older
people had so much
wisdom to share so many stories to tell
but younger doctors are into saving
things quantitatively not qualitatively
and i think the uh
i'll read the last part of the poem it
said i then took the time to get to know
some of these marvelous people
three times my age
so i'm three times the age of me when i
wrote this
who offered a wealth of experience that
spanned hundreds of years
uh what was so obviously missing was
someone to share the fullness of the
past
and to help relieve the loneliness of
the future and maybe someone to give a
damn when they died
so i think he saw that and so he says
this to me when i'm at a low point
he says mark
you didn't mess up because you passed
everything
but you are messed up
but um
if you
get unmessed up i think this school
would be glad they gave you a second
chance
and so i start to cry i mean this is
compassion and i didn't know what to do
you know you started to cry earlier in
our in our session here
and uh
and he said
he said
and even if you don't get unmessed up
even if you don't become a doctor even
if you don't do anything the rest of
your life i'd be proud to know you
because you have a streak of goodness in
you that we don't grade in medical
school
and you have no idea how much that the
world needs that goodness
and you're not going to know how much
the world needs that goodness until
you're 35
and you deserve to be on this planet
and you're going to let me help you
and he stood up to the school
here's where i get emotional
because
after that i finished med school and i
became the suicide specialist
i was the david to the dean of students
he looked into my future and he saw
someone who could do something for the
world
oh no you can't start crying you'd make
me cry again
no so it's all come full circle because
that's what he saw because
i didn't see a future for me i didn't
see any value
i didn't think the world would need me i
didn't think i could do anything
and it's just come so full circle
and and he
my future was the marble
and so i think that's how i might have
reached some of my suicidal patients is
i saw the hope inside
their hopelessness
wow
that was
amazing
thank you so much for coming on
that was really cool
uh i think people will find it helpful
i'm going to link all the links that we
talked about below
um
specifically the the teen mental health
webinar make sure that's down there
where
where can people go or what should
people where where can people go to find
you
well i have a podcast called my wake-up
call that you're going to be on your dad
was on it um
i i'll share a little anecdote i don't
know if you saw your dad's uh
interviewing i didn't i didn't yet no
it was interesting because you know
every everybody wants part of your dad's
time
yeah you know and we had met because i
was honored at a black tie gala in new
york uh for uh dr dr oz's foundation and
and i met your dad there
and so
uh so we're having the conversation with
your dad and i know everybody wants his
time
i mean
i can't tell you how many people say can
you introduce me to jordan peterson i
said i'm not that close to him you know
and and so we go for about 40 minutes
and and i'm just feeling so grateful
that he took the time to be on
and i said you know i know you're really
busy and i want to thank you for giving
me time
and you know your dad and in the podcast
he said i have more time ask me another
question
we went for another 30 minutes
nice
that's cool
that was really good you you are an
amazing storyteller
well you gave me a long leash so i hope
they i hope they were more compelling
than they were boring oh not at all they
were great you've got the timing down
perfectly it's just like
that was great that was great so thank
you very much for coming on
so the link's my wake-up call please you
know check out my podcast and and how i
use the podcast and you'll be a guest
is i don't have really a big team but i
introduce my guests to each other
when i get a sense you'll like each
other so i've had larry king on i had
norman lear who did all in the family
tom steyer who ran for president
marshall goldsmith ken blanchard esther
wojcicki
uh
sam
sam horn
margaret heffernan i get 12 requests a
week to be on
to be a guest on it but i introduce my
guests to each other
and say listen to each other's podcast
if you like each other
i'll introduce you and just go make the
world better go on come on leave me
alone just just just go make the world
and that's the whole purpose of the
podcast
that is so cool okay well i'm honored
that you would have me on i will
definitely do that
thank you again for for coming on that
was that was crazy that was really good
and they can check out michelangelo
mindset and uh
and and they can check me out on
linkedin in fact if i can stall for a
second uh that's a qr code there we go
that if people use your camera
and you focus on that it'll take you to
my linkedin profile
that's so smart
that's a really good idea i might have
to start implementing something like
that that's cool okay thank you thank
you mark thank you for coming on
thank you for the long leash we'll be in
touch
[Music]
you